I'm here with Nija,
a dev ops engineer here at Udacity.
So tell me,
how do you consume documentation
as part of an engineering team?
>> We consume documentation every day
because we use third party libraries and
tools.
So, one of the easiest things to
do is when we want to get up and
running, we look for an example for
how to do that in the documentation.
>> And what would you do if you did
not have this documentation available?
>> We would be very sad.
Realistically, we may
not use that library, or
we may switch to a library
that is better documented.
Or we might write our own
internal documentation if that's
really the library that we need to use.
>> How would you figure out the code
if the documentation wasn't there?
>> You'd have to dig through
the source code a lot of the times,
or examine it using a debugger.
Or, a number of other more
advanced trouble-shooting tools.
>> That sounds like a big headache.
>> It's kind of like reverse engineering
somebody else's thought process.
Sometimes it doesn't work so
well in practice.
>> Thanks Nija.